this is a production of Cornell
University so this is the picture I use
it seminars when I go other places and
they don't show a picture of what it
looks like now no I'm afraid I did not
so so this talk is one that would been
appropriate for plant breeding but it
also is appropriate for plant biology
because there is actually a lot of
really interesting basic research
questions that come up when you try to
do genetic engineering of photosynthesis
as you'll see but it is known that if
you increase photosynthesis you'll
increase yield and this experiment done
by Steve Long's group where they
actually have co2 flooded over fields to
see if the increase in co2 will actually
help growth and then these the average
increase in growth is about 30% if you
increase photosynthesis by giving more
co2 so this is resulted in a lot of
interest among granting agencies and
researchers to try to improve
photosynthesis because it's a trait that
actually has not really been
particularly selected for as people are
doing have done plant reading in the
past now here's a brief reminder about
photosynthesis so you all remember that
there are light reactions and then dark
reactions and there are people who are
in fact trying to improve the capture of
light energy and there are others who
are trying to you know alter the the
organization of the plant so that the
leaf is positioned better to capture the
light energy or changing the actual
biochemistry of the light capture well
I'm not going to talk about that well
we're going to leave that as a black box
and instead I'm going to talk about the
capture of co2 and then what happens
after co2 is captured so now reminder
about c3 carbon fixation as I think most
people here know the rebus co-enzyme is
possible for fixing carbon use it taking
a five carbon substrate and converting
it into two 3-carbon molecules in the
Calvin cycle that then gives you what
you want your starts sugar amino acids
and fatty acids but something bad
sometimes happens which is that Rubisco
can react with oxygen instead of co2 and
when it does you end up with
photorespiration that generates a toxic
two carbon molecule along with one three
carbon molecule so this is a real
problem you lose energy and you lose
your fixed carbon as this toxic to
carbon molecule is detoxified and
photorespiration does caused significant
loss this is an example of the loss in
soybean in different areas of the US and
this will get worse as we have global
warming because the as the temperature
goes up you will get more
photorespiration and so that math is
going to look worse after we have
continuing increases in our temperature
so there's a several groups that are
trying to alter the photo respiratory
pathway to reduce its impact and I'm
just going to tell you about one of
these that was successful because it
really does illustrate how important
altering the propensity for
photorespiration can be so you can
engineer a bypass by combining two
carbon to two carbon molecules into a
useful four carbon molecule this was
just published this past month in
science and when they did this in
tobacco they actually used tobacco as a
model system you could see you can see
in this example plant that the plant
that has the bypass has grown more than
the one that does not so this is very
promising so far it's only been tested
in tobacco but it really could help
potentially reduce the impact of
photorespiration but that's not the only
effort that people are making to reduce
photorespiration that's one of the goals
of our labs projects
so in addition to photorespiration rebus
co has another issue that causes it to
reduce their constant to affect
photosynthetic efficiency and that is
this actually has a very slow catalytic
rate only three molecules of co2 fixed
per second and that's because it's
actually a big job to fix co2 it's a
very hard thing for an enzyme to do and
this enzyme evolved in conditions that a
very low oxygen the other the issue then
another issue is that because there's a
slow catalytic rate in order to fix
enough carbon plants have evolved a high
level of production of Rubisco so that
25 to 50 percent of the leaf soluble
protein is Rubisco and that consumes 25%
of the leaf nitrogen so it has an effect
on nitrogen use as well so i'll be
talking a lot about Rubisco and i just
wanted to remind you that Rubisco has
eight small subunits encoded by the
nuclear genome and i'm going to be using
the abbreviation s su and RBC s for the
gene and eight large subunits encoded by
the chloroplast genome and i'll be
referring to the this is LSU or rbcl for
the gene so the faster the Rubisco
enzyme in general the higher
concentration of co2 is needed to for it
for its optimum function so everyone
knows that c4 plants are more productive
and can and have you know lower
photorespiration issues but you see it's
actually they're actually and they're
able therefore to use a somewhat faster
enzyme than c3 plants but the real
champion is the sign of bacteria that
can use a very fast enzyme that has very
as much lower affinity for co2 as a
result of a specialized compartment now
the c4 plant also has a mechanism to
increase co2 around Rubisco but sounda
bacteria have a better way of doing this
and that allows sauna bacteria to invest
only three to five percent of their
cellular nitrogen in Rubisco unlike what
I just told you about plants so a number
of different ways have evolved to solve
this problem of giving Rubisco co2
rather than giving it oxygen I just
mentioned the c-4 pathway there's also
the cam pathway that separates separates
the fixation in between day and night
there's the paranoid that occurs in a
lot of algae that is also a place where
Rubisco is gathered and then there's the
carboxy zone which I will be describing
today some specialized micro compartment
so my lab is currently working on two
strategies to enhance Rubisco efficiency
one is to increase the concentration of
co2 near abisco the other one is to
alter Rubisco by either mutagenesis are
taking advantage of natural variation to
have a higher specificity of co2 without
a huge reduction in the turnover rate or
to have a higher turnover rate without a
great loss in specificity for co2 well
if there is a somewhat linear
relationship between the rate of the
enzyme and the co2 specificity it's not
a perfect line and there's some some
chance of altering improving that for
example the turnover rate without
dramatically affecting the co2
specificity so I'm first going to talk
about increasing the concentration of
co2 near abisco and this has been funded
by a joint NSF BBSRC project we have
collaborators in Martin Perry's lab in
lenka at Lancaster we have a
collaborator at the University of
Glasgow a lab there and then in my lab
the three people who have worked on this
project our two postdocs my ox and
beshal and Kevin who is a BMC B student
so Santa bacteria avoid the
photorespiration problem by having a co2
concentrating like a compartment known
as a carboxy so this is a sign of
bacteria this is what these little
carboxy stones look like and this is a
diagram of what goes on
so bicarbonate enters the carboxy zone a
carbonic anhydrase inside the carboxy
some results in production of co2 right
next to abisco and that effectively
increases the atmospheric concentration
of co2 for this sign of bacteria the
question is whether we can move this
sign of bacterial carbon concentrating
mechanism into plants this very nice
diagram produced by price and how it
shows how you might know you might have
to do this so in the sign of bacterium
there are pumps that send bicarbonate
and co2 in and then inside as I
mentioned inside the sign of bacterial
compartment you you have conversion to
co2 you make you have Rubisco than
fixing carbon to transfer this to a
plant cell you will need a pump to get
more bicarbonate into the chloroplast
and that is the project being carried
out by microwatts group at glasgow and
there are other groups also interested
in trying to put more bicarbonate into
the chloroplast to facilitate
photosynthesis then you have to
synthesize the carboxy some inside the
chloroplast and and have it function
properly the model modeling was done by
a postdoc in Steve Long's lab just in
the grass and his modeling and
mathematical in silicon modeling
indicated that you could have a
potential increase in yield by as much
as 60% if you actually could get a
completely functional system into the
plant
now another hopeful sign that this might
be possible is that beta carboxy
unlike structures that have Rubisco
activity have actually been produced in
e.coli these are some of these
structures here and we also in some work
I'm not going to go into we're able to
express the shell proteins of the sign
of bacterial carboxy some in
chloroplasts and we could see little
structures but we expressed only the
shell proteins rather than all of the
carboxy some components now this this is
not yet a functional carboxy stone as it
doesn't do everything at Kibaki some can
do but it nevertheless is encouraging
that if you can assemble it in e.coli
you may be able to assemble everything
in chloroplasts so we have technology
that we need to use in order to do this
engineering and that is we can transform
the chloroplast genome if you have a
target gene you want to replace
homologous recombination occurs
naturally in in chloroplasts you don't
you don't have to have any special
targeting other than then G then
sequences on either side of your trans
genes of interest and you will end up
with a chloroplast genome that contains
your transgene and has replaced your
target gene now one reason we're using
tobacco as a model system and why most
people use tobacco as a model system is
that the fast the the plant that will
undergo this procedure and
transformation you end up with a
chloroplast transformed plant is fastest
in tobacco there's no plant that you can
do this more quickly than in tobacco
recently methods have been will be
published shortly we heard about this at
the recent Gordon conference it's now
possible to do chloroplast
transformation in a rabid OPS's but it
takes much longer and so it is still
useful for us to be doing our
experiments in tobacco so just to review
an experiment we have published we took
the strategy of replacing the tobacco
rbcl gene with cyanobacterial transgenes
along with the the most common
selectable marker SPECT in Oh mice and
resistance so we're inserting the
to a particular location in the genome
replacing removing and replacing the
tobacco rbcl so what we did is put in
both the large subunit of the Santa
bacteria and the small subunit and the
suspect ino mice and resistance gene and
then after so around the selection you
check to make sure you've gotten rid of
all the wild-type and this DNA blot
shows there's no more of the wild-type
gene there and only you have only the
trans gene present so to do this you
have to have promoters ribosome binding
sites for translation terminators and
also an expression element in between
the two genes that allows for allows
good expression levels so this is the
transgenic plant right here and this is
what wild-type looks after like after 46
days this is what this transgenic plant
looks after 50 days this is growing in
high co2 because there's no carboxy
somme in there this plant could not grow
in ambient air because in ambient co2
concentrations because there's no
carboxy so but in high co2 as you would
have if you have intact carboxy so the
plants growing quite well and this gives
an indication of the reduction in
Rubisco you might be able to make if you
have the carboxy zone present because
this is well a wild-type in air has this
much Rubisco in 3 percent co2 had a bit
less but in this transgenic plant has
much less and yet it grows almost as
fast as the Rubisco so there could be
some potential for nitrogen use
efficiency
now one other interesting thing is that
most of the tobacco small subunit is not
found I mean there's you don't see much
in plants that have both the large
subunit and small subunit from sign of
bacteria but we didn't do anything to
the nuclear genes that encode the small
subunit this just shows that the tobacco
a large subunit is gone from the
transgenic line that instead the large
subunit is present
but this also shows you that that in
this plant we can't find any of this
should actually be small subunit you
can't find any of the small subunit of
tobacco here using a specific antibody
for the anti tobacco's an anti tobacco
small subunit antibody and that must
mean that in the presence of both large
and small subunit from cyanobacteria it
provincially preferentially associates
the Santa bacterial enzyme prevent
preferentially associates and presumably
then the tobacco small subunit is just
degraded so Amiata also did another
experiment in which he made a transplant
stomach plant that had only the large
subunit of the Santa bacteria Rubisco
and no small subunit of the
cyanobacteria Rubisco so under those
circumstances can you get a hybrid
enzyme because there's there is no small
subunit of the Santa bacteria present
and surprisingly it was possible in the
absence of the sign of bacterial small
subunit to get an assembled enzyme La si
here
that in this in this plant that is a
transgenic plant that lacks the small
subunit of cyanobacteria the plants you
can see are not doing extremely well
however at high co2 the plant will grow
autotrophic Li and set seed so this
shows that in fact surprisingly that you
can actually make a hybrid enzyme and
one reason this was surprising that a
previous experiment had been done to
replace tobacco rbcl with Steiner
bacterial RB cell and it got and the
result was non autotrophic plants this
was done back in 1999 and here's what
the plant looks like that has no
functional Rubisco it then turns out
that back then there wasn't a whole lot
known about you know post translate
transcriptional and translation
modifications of Rubisco and they
inadvertently used a modified in
terminus that probably prevented the
formation of this hybrid enzyme so in
fact this unfortunate result was
actually a result of the particular
engineering of the transgene so we are
also of course trying to put the whole
carboxy stem in there and here is just
one one example of some of a transgenic
plant that was produced by me ox in
which he expressed a large number of the
other sign of bacterial components not
just the large and small subunits
but all these other components and all
of our plants currently that have a lot
of these genes look like this
they have a large glob of Rubisco in
this case you can see that it's
surrounded on the outside you know sort
of see a circle here it's it's one of
these shell proteins on the outside was
labeled with yfp and you can end using
immuno gold you could also see that the
shell is located in the proper location
but instead of a large number of small
carboxy stones we have a large blob
looks more almost like a paranoid than a
than a carboxy some so these large
bodies actually look like structures in
sign of bacteria that are present when
the carboxy stones are forming before
shale proteins are incorporated so this
is an experiment done in Cheryl kerfeld
slab in which they had a sign of
bacteria that lacked shell proteins but
were inducible they could induce the
shell proteins but they could synthesize
they synthesized all the other proteins
and then later on in turn induced the
shell proteins so the in that case the
you saw these large aggregations of
Rubisco that after the shell proteins
were induced then you got the formation
of the smaller carboxy somes so what we
think this is telling us is that we need
a higher amount
of our shell proteins in order to get
the proper assembly of the carboxy somes
so we think we're going to need to
express 12 different car box sign of
bacterial genes in order to make the
carboxy so and we'll have to express
these at proper levels and these are all
the this is a diagram of what we think
we're going to be needing and this is
this is the relative amount that's
thought to exist in the sign of bacteria
you see there's a very high amount of
this one shell protein this is a shell
protein that's one two and so we're
going to need to be able to express
chloroplast protein chloroplast genes at
different levels so another project
ongoing in the lab is really a synthetic
biology project we need a variety of
elements to control the chloroplast gene
expression we have to have particular
promoters for protein expression
translation particular ribosome binding
sites downstream boxes and then there's
RNA processing and stability is
important so you have interested
Stronach expression element terminators
and then a large number of genes so
Vishal a postdoc in the lab has taken on
the difficult task of making parts that
can then be combined in a synthetic
biology approach and he has developed
some convenient methods for sticking
together all these different parts using
BioBricks and Gibson assembly and I'm
not going to go into this but he is our
local expert on on synthetic biology
type cloning and so he's currently
making a number of constructs and
getting them into plants these are some
of the constructs that he's these parts
that he stuck together and this is work
in progress so I don't have any results
but I thought it might be interesting to
some people here interested in this type
of cloning to know that there is
somebody in my lab working on this and I
hope that we will be able to see some
little carboxy somes instead of one
gigantic mass of Rubisco in the future
so I'm now going to turn to another
aspect of making a sign of
in senator bacterial carboxy so and that
is the issue of carbonic anhydrase so
carbonic anhydrase is is catalyzes this
reaction forming either co2 or
bicarbonate and why is this important in
context of of this forming this carboxy
so
carbonic anhydrase is present in the
chloroplast stroma as nuclear encoded by
nuclear genes and but normally carbonic
anhydrase in the in the santa bacterium
is confined to the carboxy so it's not
in the cytoplasm so an experiment was
done by a group some years ago showing
that if you put if you express carbonic
anhydrase in the carboxy stone that in
the sorry in the cytoplasm that prevents
the function of b carboxy stone so
you're not you're not getting the co2 in
for the carboxy so it's getting released
in the cytoplasm and so you have a
non-functional carboxy so what that
means to us is that we need to remove
the carbonic anhydrase that's present in
the chloroplast stroma if we're going to
be able to have a functional carboxy
cell so a separate line of research in
the lab is to remove the carbonic
anhydrase so this work is being carried
out by Kevin Hines who is a BMC B
student so as I mentioned we have to
remove the stromal carbonic anhydrase if
we want to have carboxy some function so
Kevin identified the two chloroplast
carbonic anhydrase --is that are present
in the chloroplast it turns out that
this one C a1 is not only in
chloroplasts it's also in the cytoplasm
also in stromal and BC a5 however is
only in chloroplasts so you can see here
that there also it's also instruments
Kevin generated CRISPR mutants to find
out what happens when you get rid of CA
one and CA five so these are CRISPR
mutants lacking carbonic anhydrase one
and the plant looks perfectly normal and
it grows normally and in air it's fine
and this BC a5 also the plant grows
normally it's fine
when you grow it in air however if you
have a double mutant the double mutant
looks like this on sucrose in air now
the fact that it looks like this on
sucrose means that it's not just
photosynthesis that's being impaired
because for example we've had in the lab
a mutants tobacco that lacks
chloroplasts RNA polymerase can't make
any any chloroplast transcripts at all
so what do you get you get perfectly
shaped white leaves a perfectly
normal-looking tobacco plant except that
the leaves are white so so there's
something else going on here because
that plant can't photosynthesize and but
this one looks really abnormal even on
sucrose however if you move this to high
co2 the plant phenotype normalizes and
these you can't really distinguish this
from wild-type so what happens in high
co2 there'll be some natural formation
of bicarbonate because you've driven the
reaction with high co2 so they'll be
play carbonate spontaneously formed not
by an enzyme but just performed in the
chloroplast by spontaneous reaction so
what happens when you move this plant
back to co2 I went back to ambient air
so you move this plant back to ambient
air and this is when the plant was was
moved back so all subsequent leaves are
really abnormal on that plant and the
leaves that had already been formed are
stay-stay wild-type looking
and of course can support the growth of
these abnormal leaves but clearly
something is going on here that the
plant can't form normal leaves without
carbonic anhydrase in the in the stroma
so one question then is can we rescue
this abnormal phenotype by expressing
carbonic anhydrase in the cytoplasm but
not the chloroplast as I mentioned that
carbonic anhydrase one is present in
both the cytoplasm and the chloroplast
we just got rid of it and then is it
really the catalytic activity that's
important for of this carbonic anhydrase
or is actually the carbonic anhydrase
and moonlighting enzyme that's doing
something else and that you're really
needing it for some other purpose so
Kevin took the double mutants and then
transformed various constructs into it
to test these questions so if you put a
35s carbonic anhydrase in target you
know targeted to the chloroplasts in the
plant phenotype normalizes but if you
remove the chloroplast transit sequence
that targets it into the chloroplast
then the plant is not doing well like
the double mutant this basically looks
like the double mutants and if you also
expressed under the control of 35s
promoter a plant that's got some point
mutations that wipe out the activity of
the enzyme the phenotype is not rescued
so it's clear that you need the
chloroplast localization and you need to
have the active enzyme if you want to
have a normal plant at ambient co2 so
what does this do for our prospects of
making carboxy so that's functional
we'll hope one thing we don't yet know
is if you install the carboxy stone and
have the carbonic anhydrase inside the
carboxy stone will that be enough to
rescue the phenotype it's possible that
having it inside the carboxy stone will
still allow production of you know of
something that is needed
but it seems unlikely actually so
another strategy is to express the
carbonic anhydrase during leaf
development get the plant leaves to look
like this and then turn off the carbonic
anhydrase so that your carboxy sim can
take over and function
it's also possible we can find out what
the carbonic anhydrase is doing and then
bypass its requirement for leaf
development but the other aspect of this
that I'd like to mention is that this
has really opened up an entirely new
basic research area in the lab which is
why is carbonic anhydrase required for
early leaf development so it's very
unexpected and just shows you can
investigate one question and then you
come up with a new question that's very
interesting so this I would like to
invite you to in to a future seminar by
Kevin who is going to be graduating this
summer he has a lot more data than I
presented I didn't give all his data on
on his project and I'm hoping that
between now and this summer he'll also
get a lot more information about what if
Y is carbonic anhydrase required for
this early leaf so I'd like now is to
turn to my last topic which is the idea
of mutagen izing Bisco to have this
higher specificity or using natural
variation to to get higher specificity
for co2 without ruining the rates of the
enzyme or to have higher turnover rate
without losing the specificity and this
again is project that neots is carrying
out under funding by the Department of
Energy so previous studies in Rubisco
mutagenesis we're almost all carried out
in prokaryotes and climate opponents the
reason that climbing to monas was used
for this is that the climbing of Mona's
chloroplast transformation is relatively
quick you can get chloroplast
transformation transform it in a few
weeks around rather and and therefore
test a lot of different possible
alterations and climbing amount in
Rubisco
but one problem is that the climbing to
Mona's Rubisco involved in the presence
of a carbon concentrating mechanism
because it has this paranoid which
functions as a carbon concentrating
mechanism so the Rubisco that you start
with in climbing a mones has a carbon
concentrate has evolved in the presence
of this carbon concentrating mechanism
so you're starting at a different point
than a c3 plant Rubisco would be so as I
said the main reason for the generation
for using climbing to Monas is because
it takes so long to make a trance place
don't make tobacco you start with
bombarding you have to wait weeks to get
a little plant like this you then
usually have to take that little plant
and select it again to get rid of all of
the wild-type chloroplast gene that's
present you have to check then and if
you may have to put it back into the
selection if it's not homo plasmic which
means you have only the transgene
president and none of the wild-type gene
so in all in all it takes about three
months so it's really somewhat of a
lengthy process to do this experiment in
plants that's why it was great to have
this breakthrough by the higher harder
lab which was assembly of active Rubisco
in e.coli a number of groups had tried
to do this for years including our own
but she beat everyone to it and one of
the key things was being able to express
these five chloroplast chaperones so
david stern's lab actually had a role in
that in that his lab had been
investigating chaperones and identifying
chaperones like bsd 2 so once all the
chaperones were identified and expressed
in e.coli it became possible to assemble
active plant Rubisco so here's a from
their december this is from their their
2018 science paper and so this is a
rabid OPS's being assembled in Rubisco
assembled in e.coli here and then they
also checked where they could assemble
tobacco Rubisco and they did get some
assembly but rather poor assembly so
this is tobacco
the Arabidopsis assembly now when they
had changed their plasmids expressed in
e.coli to add one of the de cochon of
chaperones they got somewhat better
Assembly of the tobacco Rubisco in
e.coli was still not very good so we
wanted to be able to assemble tobacco
Rubisco and e.coli for our purposes
since we then could test in our
transgenic plants so we received these
plasmids from her lab and meok did
further engineering of these two
plasmids so first he he actually put the
small subunit in the large subunit gene
in into one of those plasmas so he could
have a two component to plasmid system
instead of a three plasmid system making
it easier to do the manipulations and
when he did that and also tested
different strains of E coli he was able
to get some LA - si assembled so that
was very promising and then he altered
some additional things so instead of
using the Arab adopts Asst chaperone
genes he replaced the CPM gene with
Nkosi Anna and he put in the growth
using the grow yes from a koi and then
driving using a t7 and promoter to
increase the expression of the tobacco
small subunit now doing that he was able
to greatly improve the expression of the
of the Assembly of the Rubisco so if you
look at these three here those are all
nicely assembled Rubisco in in e.coli so
then he moved on and replaced two more
of the chaperone Arab adopts of
chaperones with the tobacco versions of
those chaperones and he got some more
minor improvements so here got some
minor improvement by
putting all tobacco chaperones in the
e.coli so this is a really usable amount
of assembled tobacco in in e.coli so
this allowed him to ask this question so
are the tobacco Rubisco enzymes in any
coli similar to the native Rubisco so
remember that I said the large subunit
is always encoded in the chloroplast
genome with a single sequence but
tobacco and other flowering plants have
multiple nuclear genes encoding the
Rubisco small subunit so even a rabid
OPS's has forced an all subunit genes
so a typical Rubisco could be one that
had three of one subunit and one of
another this one would would have maybe
a different subunit and so there's
probably multiple forms of Rubisco
present in plants depending on what what
small subunit is expressed but in our
eco lie we're expressing a single small
subunit so we're actually looking at a
homogenous homogeneous Rubisco that has
you know only one type of small subunit
so that allows us to ask well is there a
difference between these different small
subunits and the enzymes that results
from them so in tobacco unfortunately it
has 11 loci and these these Trenton
these expressing transcripts that have
seven unique small subunits now there's
11 low sites some of the transcript
sequences are identical so you only have
seven unique small subunits well tobacco
has the further complicate complication
that it's an alloy tetraploid so you
have small subunits that were derived
from Silvestre as' and some that were
derived from tomentosa formas and it's
clear that these s 1 s 2 and T 1 are the
predominantly expressed at least at the
RNA level and I hope to find out
perhaps with classes help what what what
the expression is at the protein level
but right now this is the information we
have at the RNA level also it's been
recently discovered that
non that that there's another small
subunit present in non-photosynthetic
tissues which is a surprise discovery
and this trichome Rubisco that it's been
found it's it's also not only in
trichomes but in some other tissues
appears to have a lower affinity for co2
and a faster catalytic rate so this was
a surprise discovery that there may be a
Rubisco that's doing something other
than photosynthesis that is present in
this non green tissue and this small
subunit in the trichome of tobacco is
quite different than a typical small
subunit present in in a leaf that's
expressed in a leaf so I think an
interesting area is going to be why do
plants have this trichome Rubisco what
is it doing so Mia
then tested each one of these expressed
subunits although all of them in his
system so each one of these lanes is a
different eco line line expressing
either that s 1 s 2 s 5 or the T 1 etc
and he was able to get assembly into l 8
and s 8 of most of these although
something that is so and then well do
they have any activity probably
wondering about that it turns out that
these do have good Rubisco activity in
fact the one is that has the highest
activity is actually this trichome
Rubisco what's very surprising is that
this one had activity because it's not
at the right place there's something
weird going on about the assembly of
this one but it still has some activity
nevertheless there's a lot of these that
have good activity and therefore it
could be used first in mutagenesis
experiments so looking at the kinetic
more detail at the kinetic data for the
seven forms of Rubisco each one of them
was analyzed with regard to its Casey
you know reaction with co2 and its speed
and what's interesting is that tobacco
Rubisco that's in e.coli has a slightly
lower affinity for Co - here's the
native and these higher numbers indicate
that these have lower affinity for co2
their rates is actually pretty good if
you compare the you know 2.5 there's
pretty good rates here in in the e.coli
system what's interesting is that again
the trichome in e.coli just like in
plants has a lower affinity for co2 and
a higher catalytic rate so this means
that we can alter Rubisco and study
Rubisco that's been altered in e.coli
and then take those genes that have
interesting properties you know higher
perhaps higher turnover rate better
specificity and then put them in the
plant and see what happens
so me--off has created a line that is
useful for this purpose it lacks the
spec t no mice and resistance gene this
has been removed but it has the two sign
of bacterial we're to sign of bacterial
subunit genes and then you can take your
tobacco large subunit that's mutated and
recombine into this plant and end up
with the tobacco mutated large subunit
now why do you need to do this rather
than putting this into wild-type why not
just do wild-type well it turns out if
you've only mutated a few amino acids
here there's going to be recombination
unfortunately with your wild type
tobacco and your lose your mutations so
this gives us a way to different to
definitely stick in the large subunit of
tobacco mutated version into this
transgenic plant however you'd really
like to be able to put in both the large
and the small subunit not just the large
subunit mutated that's what we're doing
in e.coli both the large and the small
Semyon that we're mutating and and and
and we'll see what happens so that we
would like to be able to put both the
tobacco large subunit and small subunit
into our transgenic line and see what
happens when we mutate both of them or
mutate one at a time so in order to be
able to do this we have to get rid of
the tobacco small subunit so in fact
another project that Vishal is carrying
out is to remove all the RBC s genes
from tobacco by CRISPR and it's
progress he's gotten rid of a number of
them but we have to get rid of the rest
of them in order to be able to do this
experiment so I'm going to end here with
a summary and what I've told you about
is is that we have succeeded assembling
active Santa bacteria Rubisco and that
they grow quite rapidly in in high co2
indicating there can some hope for doing
this engineering and that we
unexpectedly we can actually make a
hybrid Rubisco with cyanobacteria
tobacco subunits Vishal has made parts
of a synthetic biology cloning strategy
to be able to mix and match different
genes and gene expression elements
easily surprisingly tobacco lacking
expression of carbonic anhydrase has is
impaired in early leaf development we're
going to now be able to use this tobacco
Rubisco system in e.coli to explore
generation of new and interesting
enzymes and we can then put those into
plants hopefully both the large and
small subunit after we get CRISPR small
subunit music mutagen s you know Genesis
thank you
[Applause]